[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the Big Bang which I need to remember to
not call the Big Bang Theory because
I've done that before so I mentioned
last time that I normally do two parters
as a single story and this time I'm not
because I don't feel that these flow
together very well as two halves of a
single narrative nor do I think that
this is very good which is a shame
because Pandorica opens was great and it
actually may be one of those cases where
Pandorica opens was so strong in terms
of setting up a situation that they
shouldn't be able to get out of and with
so many layers to it you know between
the universe ending and the TARDIS
exploding and the doctor and the
Pandorica and Amy being killed and Rory
is plastic and got so much going on that
maybe there was no way to wrap it up
other than what this episode does and if
that's the case maybe I should hold it
against Pandorica opens a little bit for
doing too much at once but end of the
day but Pandorica opens works and this
doesn't so why doesn't it why do I
dislike this episode as much as I do
because I really do get the sense that
I'm in a minority opinion on this so
allow me to explain the big thing on
this for me is especially following the
very emotional climax of the previous
one where it really felt like everything
was lost and all hope was gone this not
only opens very weakly I know it's
trying to mirror the first episode of
the series but like tonally it's a week
start and it stalls and then it just
doesn't feel like it's picking up from
the threat and then it immediately
launches into what I think is the
fundamental issue with it which is a
sense of tone and of stakes this doesn't
have the feel of we have to save the
universe this has the feel of Moffat
going okay watch me tie up all these
plot threads I'm so clever this is an
hour long tying up of narrative threads
and given what a tangle of narrative
threads the previous episode was that's
no small feat but the problem is that's
kind of all it does it tries Turing
emotion out of the tail end of it and
gets a little but not a lot I mean you
can kind of tell just from the
soundtrack it uses some of the goofier
tracks from Ari Gold at points in this
like early on and again it's like aren't
we supposed to be saving the the
universe here why is the music doing the
GDD you know goofy end of things where's
the sense of danger where's the sense of
the encroaching threat it's not there
because this isn't about the threat this
is about watch me fix all the all of the
timeline and watch me be clever with
paradoxes and I'm allowed to get away
with them this time because times
collapsing anyway so I can do it this
time and who I'm so clever in here's
this and it connects to this and now
they do this and to make sure that the
make sure that the sonic is in the
inside pocket and ooh take that that
soda from little Amy and give it a
little Amy again later ooh clever and
again on a if you were to diagram out
this episode yeah
it's clever but that's all it is it
doesn't leave me feeling anything other
than okay that's kind of clever I guess
except it's also not as clever as it
thinks it is
the big instance of that is Amelia so
Amelia is at the start again so that we
can mirror the opening of the series
again and they give a logistical
narrative justification for why she has
to be there in the Pandorica needs her
DNA or whatever but I I keep banging
this drum justifying something narrative
Lee doesn't suddenly make it actually
work and flow and function properly he
just means you came up with that excuse
as to why you did it that way but
anyways my problem with little Amelia is
she is there until she is an
inconvenience and then she literally
disappears that's the level that this is
that this thing is working out it's
going to introduce something and keep it
there for as long as it has mechanical
plot function and as soon as she no
longer does she is gone literally
vanished from the episode from the story
and I'm sorry that's really lazy that's
really easy and really lazy and again I
understand the narrative justification
for how Moffat thinks he got away with
that I don't care if it's justified
that's a really lazy thing to do to take
a character who no longer has function
and is now inconvenient and literally
have them vanish that it that is the
that is the hand of the writer very
heavy on this story and I also don't
like the fact that the way the entire
Big Bang to thing plays out okay so the
universe ended not the planet blew up
not you know something horrible happens
in time the universe ends and in fact
never existed at all but by the end of
this story there are no consequences to
that
I brought this up when I talked about
the end of series 3 and the fact that
what I really hated about the last of
Time Lords isn't what the master does or
that the doctor defeats him it's the one
year rollback so that aside from a
handful of people nobody ever knew it
happened in other words there are no
tangible lasting consequences to that
having happened and my big problem with
that is if you're going to go big there
have to be consequences to that and if
you're not gonna have consequences don't
go that big don't blow up the universe
if at the end of the story you would
never know that that had happened if you
were to pick up series 6 and or if for
whatever reason skip this two-parter
finale
jump right to series 6 and someone were
to tell you oh did you know that the
universe ended and was restarted oh no I
didn't I never could have told you that
there's no consequences to this and if
you're not gonna have consequences don't
go that big on the threat just don't and
like that really gets under my skin
what is the tangible difference at the
end of this amy has her parents back
well yay good for her we're never gonna
see them again so for us is an audience
that doesn't matter that nothing is
different their memories are all back
and the history apparently when you
reboot the universe plays out exactly
the same as it did last time because I
guess chaos theory and the butterfly
effect aren't things everything is
exactly the same nothing is different
status quo maintained after literally
blowing up everything no no no no that
just no
and again like to give credit it's not
unclever Lee constructed in terms of
solving the plot but that's the thing it
takes the ending of the previous episode
where all these things happened and
doesn't treat it like a story it treats
it like a puzzle okay how do I put it
back together and while it's not
necessarily uninteresting to see how
that gets done it's not especially
engaging especially not emotionally you
know what it's a bit like this episode
and I'm probably gonna stretch the
metaphor a little bit but go with me on
this it's a bit like finding out how a
magician does a trick yeah it's still
kind of impressive but it's not nearly
as magical as when you just saw the
trick and I feel like Moffat is so eager
to show off how he's going to fix this
and put on full display the mechanics of
what he's gonna connect to this and this
and this and this to fix this problem he
created that it's like he's just showing
us the back the backstage mechanics of
the trick which again is not
uninteresting but doesn't land the same
and I had our oil I've been talking
about plot and structure and feel and
tone and flow performances are fine
actually they're great even Rory and Amy
are terrific the doctor is really good
he has some great really funny moments
they like low-key funny I love when he
first sort of sits up from having flown
depend or Canon because oh I escaped I
love it when I do that I love little
things like that I like the fez I like
River Song facing down the Dalek and
it's asking for mercy and she says I'm
River Song check your memory again if
you think I'm gonna show you mercy like
there are good moments sprinkled across
this
but again they're just sprinkled over it
the through line is watch me untie this
knot that I tied the plot into last time
and the emotional engagement it tries to
get it in the tail end with the doctor
you know trying to get Amy to remember
and ties it back to flesh and stone
which again clever but it doesn't get me
emotionally the way I want it to the way
that the doctor think he's going to die
should get me nor does his return and
Amy bringing him back feel as triumphant
as it should not for me at any rate
maybe it works better for everybody else
it seems to whenever I say I don't
really like this I get really weird
looks but that's the best that I can do
to explain why I do not really care for
the Big Bang
Yuri watched it lately what are your
thoughts on it whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it does a bunch of stuff to
doubt to do down there as well because
you can like subscribe you can support
me on patreon which helps me keep this
whole thing going plus there are other
things as well links to my social
there's my p.o box book I wrote and
click on stuff it'll take you places but
you also don't have to because at the
end of the day you are the council I'm
just running the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]